folks joe derosa here from the taste
buds podcast hi taste buddies i got
dates coming up all over the place i
will be in atlantic city in august in
september i'll be in san diego
uh then i'm going to be in north
carolina i'm going to be in vegas i'm
going to be all over so just go to
jodarossa jodarossainfo.com for all
ticket links and tour and show
information also please as always check
out joey rose's in new york city on the
lower east side bar and sandwich shop
and social club we're running six days a
week opening at 12 p.m every day go to
joeyrosesnyc.com for details
fear not if you didn't hear your city
these just went on sale for the fall
they're all on sale right now hamilton
ontario toronto richmond virginia
hershey pennsylvania knoxville tennessee
atlanta georgia birmingham alabama
louisville kentucky evansville indiana
jacksonville tampa and orlando florida
sacramento san jose and santa rosa
california if you didn't hear your city
i'm going to be adding more for the new
year but i'm grinding out there guys i'm
listening to you guys online when you
tell me come here come there i'm taking
into consideration so if you know
someone from those areas let them know
i'm coming through everything's on sale
right now volcano comedy.com thanks guys
tastebuds they coming to the mic talking
about the food they hate talking about
the food they like two fools gonna fight
but only one food can be right
welcome to t-a-s-t-e
so we're sitting here in our new setup
i hope this doesn't bother me
these these guys are bothering me don't
don't look stay focused stay focused
look at me look at me well don't look at
it
i know
it's a snake plant but it's got it's
long and it's got pointy edges i mean
the fact that something even exists
called a snake plant why would they name
it that unclear of all the things to
name it i get it because the body looks
like the leaves look like a snake body
really but that's not something you want
to think about you know what i mean
i don't know man this is like so south
seven heart attempt to snake plant he
asked me where my head's at right before
we started i'm talking about so two
episodes back
which were also shot today
yeah
we talked about how my car died today i
got to get rid of it yeah
and i'm leaving town in two days
[Music]
to go on the road
and all i can think about is
do i do i i should not go try to get a
new car
in the two free days i have
before i leave i need to just be patient
or not but all i'm gonna be thinking
nobody gets a car in two days
oh i i go the day of and and what
happens and i walk off the lot with it
and what happens
not this usually i swear this was a
particular nobody gets a car in two days
that's what i'm telling you
i go i go and i
yeah yeah pay at prices yeah test drive
do a read some articles
ask some friends buy a consumer reports
mag my point is is i shouldn't even
visit a lot in the next two days is my
point
like but but i will pointless you're
going away for a week assumed by it yeah
that's all i will think about
and you know what
i don't need to do that i can i can get
my work done and i don't have to do that
yeah you know yesterday i had a great
day yesterday can i tell you about it
yeah i'm gonna have to do something
about this plan
[Music]
why is it neither here it's not in a
shot
but right now that window's not on okay
let's take this out
let's do that is it bothering you
because it's in the shot no no the
points
i know it's the thing with the points
but what is the thing with the points
pam
you can't be anything i'm a lunatic
because i am
can you move the plant can you move the
plant
uh like behind the table all of this has
to stay in so i don't even see it please
like just someone yeah why would you
have a perfect pimp but my question is
why would you have a plant like this in
your home well i don't normally sit next
to it but you can see it though it
you're not sitting next to it there it's
across the room my point is you can see
it it bothers you it's hard to explain i
know because it's irrational so it's
hard to explain i know it's irrational
i'm not saying it's irrational i'm
asking what it is i bring it into your
heart to bother you that's the basis of
it is irrationality and it's it's just
uh
it doesn't bother me unless i'm
sensitive that day or unless i notice it
and then my i get hyper focused on it
and now it's there and if i see it over
there
something about it makes me want to
shield my eyes i don't know what it is
it's terrible i i hate this
it's it's
i i wish if anyone's watching and knows
anything about this i guess it's ocd
it's such an interesting uh ocd how do i
stop this
because it affects my life
i have to adjust pillows i have to like
move i think at this point anything
short of electro shock therapy it's not
gonna really i think you gotta restart
your brain just completely
[Music]
what's like the most traumatizing in
public points yeah okay so
uh a plane is bad because if someone's
sitting next to me or or the train if
they're reading like a newspaper or mag
and that like they have it open and
their points are hanging in my face
yeah well if i well if i know the person
i outright tell them i can't even have
my passenger i can't even have her look
at the mail
in the car when i'm driving and she's
right there and she's flipping through
mail this i i hate it it's a mental
prison if
the worst thing good please i was going
to say if you're now if you're on a
plane though and there's points next
turn the other way close my eyes my
point is is if you put on an eye mask
for instance you'd be fine or inside the
mask are you no no
no but i need the right eye mask because
i can't have an eye mask that's pushing
on my eyes either because that that's
like getting the poke that i don't want
okay
the worst time i've ever had so it's a
fear of a poke
yeah it's points okay the the the it's
not but it's not a fear of a poke right
because the plant's over there now right
so it's not gonna the plant was gonna
poke me here but it it just it's grating
to my eyes i don't know what it is i
don't know what it is so my worst case i
ever had was in 99
i went on my first ever job interview
out of college
and i sat down and the guy was at his
desk and he was right there and i sat in
in front of his desk his desk was right
here it had stacks and stacks of papers
on it all angled toward me and then it
had he had like his name plate they used
to have these old school name plates
with your nameplate and there would be
two pens in them two like fountain pens
and they were both turned so that they
were aiming out toward me they were like
cajole they were like someone moved them
and so i had two pens
right at me and all the papers i'm gonna
talk about your 45-minute interview
you're having a tough time i mean let's
say you're in the seat i remember i was
sitting in the seat because when because
he's he's someone i can't tell that to
so then i just got to deal with it and
when i had to deal with it like i just
start like my inside of my head is going
bonkers you're gonna have a hard time
let's say you're a loose cannon cop but
you're getting called down to the
mayor's office for a good talking to for
your latest bout of antics okay
you know he's got those two pens in the
plate it's gonna be bad
it's gonna be bad and i so i didn't know
what to do so i'm talking to the guy
like this for like 45 minutes
and then i remember what i was doing i
was curling my feet up inside my shoes
into a ball and like squeezing to take
the attention away from that in my head
to down down so for like 45 minutes i
was going like this on my feet i think
bruce willis did it in die hard on the
plane and uh
and uh
i got the job but
yeah it was it was it was like it was so
it's so weird to explain to you guys
nothing's going through my head except
my insides freaking out it's it's it's
i i literally am getting like i get like
i get like
uncomfortable worked up tense very tense
my eyes start to hurt but it affects
everything my vision also i am sensitive
to light my eyes are sensitive i don't
know what it is
so you are yeah you too right i told you
sometimes i watch television with glass
sunglasses on
yeah but i wonder is it like the feeling
when you're a little kid you turn off
the basement lights but you're still
down there and you have to run from the
dark
well that's that's a whole nother bag of
worms but no it's terrible yeah that
that is so sad for you so my
grandparents basement had the stairs
they were like old-school houses the
house was like 100 years old and he had
wooden steps so the wooden steps were
just planked so you could see right
through
so you know what that is that's a hand
come and i have to grab your ankle and
drag you to hell so i would shut the
light off in the basement and then run
but i would do a run almost like a
gazelle like because i would i would
like it was almost like i was doing
ballet i would tip like the the foot
couldn't touch the step for more than
like a half a second and then i'd pull
it up high i high stepped up the steps
because you knew you knew a demon was
coming out of there or a murderer to
grab me by the ankles that's funny man
that made me to this day i do that still
i don't like when when when monsters or
anything like that can take you from
these from the steps i don't know why
that just made me think of
it dude
no it's true though that made me think
of seinfeld uh do people think with
lunatics yeah yeah that made me think of
i don't know why but everyone has their
own little hands
goes timito
that's that's that's that's the song the
warning signal right yeah yeah yeah yeah
we didn't work when he's trying to
switch the attribution tape we need a
warning
that's an early that's that's that might
be episode one no no no no no that's
about season three
that's when that season don't know about
that season that season two or three
it's two maybe that's that's that's in
when they're that's that's one of the
episodes where it's like they're fi
they've they hit the sound they found it
yeah
pimp where'd you get these pants by the
way because i'm looking for new plaid
pants
express
are they lightweight i'm looking for
summer plaid pants where is there an
express in the city
all right that's what i'm doing
i might do that tonight yesterday closet
cleaning and i got a night a lot of nice
what's your waist size
these days about a 34. okay what do you
got
i probably they're probably 36s okay but
i got some really nice pairs of pants
that i probably wouldn't rock anymore i
kind of like and some of them i never
even worn they're like tags on they
might have to do a little hem job but i
got some nice pass all right i'll take a
i'll tell you i don't have the time to
do it today but anytime you guys come
back take a look we'll take a look but
i'm looking for do they have any do they
have a variety of plaids
all right i'm looking for summer plaid
pants
but it was nice you know that i like to
rock a plaid oh i love it i love it yeah
but so i'm going to go i'm going to find
an express maybe this evening shake my
mind off the car excavating pants you
know what express was before it was
expressed i think i'm pretty sure
structure
the kid knows his retail the kid knows
his retail i used to live at structure
structure was my [ __ ]
10th grade it was like the only like at
that time it it hit our fashion at that
time i mean now i would i probably
wouldn't wear anything from it but like
it hit off and there's so few stores
that are like no no this is all guys
nobody had a stroke
back all the way to the sides we have a
huge variety and it's it's actually
contemporary i sound like an old person
saying that but like it's it's like not
like [ __ ] like an old person store
it was actually a young
it was like express but for men but
before it
and nobody had their big thing was
almost like a larry david style shirt it
was their big thing was like these
collared shirts that were long sleeve
but not button-ups
and they had stripes
structure always had like a striped like
pullover
like the exact style of shirt that larry
david always wears on the show except
they were like stripes he was a sports
coat doesn't he whenever he wears a
shirt whenever he wears a shirt with no
jacket it's always the collared shirt
with three buttons here oh the polo and
longs no but it's long sleeves yeah
structures thing was like it was like a
striped
stripes
not anymore but when i when we were in
the 10th grade that was like the [ __ ]
dude like those were the shirts
there are other stories we had one
called merry-go-round but that was more
like a little bit after structure it was
more like
if that's a whenever we talk my mall
jobs yeah my first one was
merry-go-round no way
really all commission that's one of the
things another thing that put me off the
stores was working commission at
merry-go-round yeah merry-go-round
merry-go-round was on and then and then
the staten island wall for all of
pope's uh peeps watching folks watching
i just mixed folks and peeps uh bang
bang was a store that was out in the
early the late 90s early 2000s and it
was like where you went to get your
like
club outfit for the weekend
it was horrific clothing oh yeah warm
books
remember one books oh yeah walden used
to go up against uh walden was one of
the big time joe you gotta cover your
mouth
i mean in normal life but in these times
you're just blowing it out into
everybody and i'm sorry i went over that
way i got nervous that i was going to
whoa
no there was a lot
there was a lot going on i shot it right
into the air no i just i didn't it just
there was no snot expel
i got a little nervous i got nervous
that i was take us through it when what
happened when when did you get nervous
that what i just panicked that i was
going to sneeze your way so then i
turned and then i was going to cover my
and then i was like what if i get
something on my hand then i touched on
my and i was like but if you don't get
something on your hand that means
nobody's over there that's a clear but
but you didn't know if you want to get
something on your hands so rather you
get it on the carpet i i knew i wasn't
going to get anything onto the car i
don't know i just panicked leave me
alone i'm sorry nothing came out i was a
that was a move man i got very nervous
please don't ever do that again i
do you think i did it on purpose
god yeah you're not in a good you're not
in a good way i panicked i'm sorry i
don't want to do this to you both but if
you if you go on youtube and put in
don't do it because i can't watch it
right i can't want to think about it
actually i'm sorry i brought it up
because i'm not going to get out of my
head now why you can do it i won't look
but you put in slow
put in like microsoft i don't know if i
want to see it either what is it like
like slo-mo sneeze like micro
microscope i don't want to say that
what i don't want to see that
it comes out like 100 miles an hour and
it's so much more than you think and
that's what i saw when you just did what
you did i apologize i panicked i just
panicked it is amongst the closest
things you'll ever see um it's just i
panicked i'm sorry i apologize
oh come on
that's not that didn't just happen
stop it
that's not even what i'm talking about
what i'm talking about is a fine mist
that covers a lot of ground in a little
time i close i kept almost everything
shut i panic see like that and so so see
yeah that's what it really really really
looks like
i don't believe that she's spraying so
you understand but if you put it in a
real what they they have they filmed
them
i don't believe that look at that look
at that he's wearing they dyed the mist
and he's wearing a under a black light
look at what's all over him that is all
over us right now it's not all over us
at worst case scenario it's all in this
area of carpet
and nobody's ever going to eat off of
that area of carpet
and it was an accident but i panicked
but it doesn't just go to the carpet it
goes it's just it's such a fine mist it
goes into the air there's not listen man
listen
uh sneezing or farting what would you
rather he done
fart
i can't catch [ __ ]
yeah that's [ __ ] party well he's just
got his pants on
his nose or his [ __ ]
but i'm saying like he's not gonna get
me sick from
dude not gonna get you sick i'm not sick
you don't know me and you don't know my
immune system i do i know your immune
system very well actually i i'm not
better than me yeah i i've been i've
been around you long enough i don't know
how it works it's absurd
uh yeah no i know i i i
i i i i panicked we're not all perfect i
understand that no one is perfect i
understand that this is age-old thing
but but what did you panic about
that i was gonna god forbid sneeze
toward you then i got nervous i was
gonna get something on my hand touch the
mic i'm sorry i wasn't familiar with the
inside out uh investigative reporting to
sneeze miss oh look at that look at that
look at that i don't wanna look at it
look at it look at it look at it or
whatever this is inside edition whatever
oh my god
anyway look at that it was an accident
that's all things we don't see
um the thing i am hung up on yeah
oh the thing yeah let's let's put an s
on the end of that word
the one thing the thing i'm hung ups on
is though the thing i know yeah
well you know uh is that you you were
scared to get stuff on your hand so i
would rather you get it on your hand get
up go wash your hand you were like i'm
gonna get on on my hand i might get snot
on my hand then you just no i wasn't
scared that i would get out of my head i
was scared that i would get something on
my hand and then touch the mic and be
disrespectful to the eq i just panicked
i
panicked i made a mistake
we'll move on
do you ever make a mistake what's it
like in your world where you never make
a mistake
tell me one mistake i don't make i'm not
gonna sneeze on you i didn't sneeze on
you i didn't sneeze on anybody i went
like this and nothing came out you
sneezed on everybody oh my god you
sneezed on everybody
you know that right if you sneezed into
the open air with us sitting here you
sneezed on us and i swear to god this is
not just i'm not joking i swear to god
i'm starting to get a little bit of a
like like a headache and a little bit of
a sore throat you are
psychotic
i know my body you are psychotic
he actually thought that the episode
where i started to get sick during it he
literally goes after you left he goes
would i be having symptoms already i was
like do you have any concept how
anything works
okay so if i have a symptom tomorrow is
that you
that could be
that's not what i said though i'll let
you know i didn't
know if any symptoms
pretty much
oh my god
i just can't afford to get sick that's
the reason i also hate it i can't afford
to get sick
i can't stop down
my i was blessed uh blessed i was cursed
with like i think like a low rent curse
that my common cold is always severe
i never have a light comedy i never have
a common cold i brush off or get rid of
in two days it never happens
not too bad
he has severe ones but he also has the
ones where he's done in a couple days
i'm not i don't know many people like
that but my common cold is two to six
weeks
two to six weeks swear to god
swear to god
stop it but you see you see how it's
unbelievable this is why i'm so much
like this because it's actually true
and it's wild and i've got news for you
let's put you in a bubble somewhere
and call it a day and that's it oh i
can't do that there's probably
government grants for people
[Music]
i don't know man you'll share you you
have actively and offered to share
glasses with me
that you've drank out of
no that's not a common practice at all
you 100 have said hey have a sip
you've offered me bites of things out of
a glass that that's that you're using
what would i give you a sip out of
well you've had a drink where i said how
how is that we'll go to a cocktail bar
for instance i say how is that one no
it's good you want to taste it maybe
you're taking a quick sip from the
opposite side of the glass buddy that is
so much worse than me sneezing onto the
floor
that is so much worse for your for germs
when you're chewing it you're not
sneezing the sneeze is loaded with germs
no
no
this the sneeze it is true that a sneeze
in our cough can expel the germs from
your body if you're sick or whatever but
my point is is i don't i'm not sick
right now and if we were to share a
glass right now you would have so much
higher risk of getting
versus me sneezing opposite away from
you towards the ground
you're caught up but you're sneezing
down you sneezed and it went into this
room everywhere that's that's what i
know it didn't if you didn't cover it it
did it didn't i went down the science is
it's been there before we were here okay
the other thing is is that i don't
really recall giving you sips of drinks
you have 100 offered me sips out of
drinks that i've said what does that
taste like you freely offered me bites
of things
i mean i'm just saying if for a man
that's paranoid about germany i would
never offer you a bite of something
unless you broke it off or ate it from
the other side then i didn't eat around
your bite i'd never done that in my life
i'm hyper aware of that i wouldn't let
you bite i wouldn't buy the sandwich
then you take the bite where my body
doesn't bite again
hell no never not you not knowing what
i'm saying even if i'm biting from
another part you don't think that [ __ ]
can get into it that's gross to me
i i i don't give you you're saying these
things yet
i'm asking you to name the time that it
happened i i just told you a time no no
when we have been in a craft cocktail
place and i've said when have i been in
the craft cocktail now we've gone to a
lot of cocktail you know that we have
stop it okay and i've said to you how's
the one you got and you've said it's
good take a sip okay maybe i've done
that it goes against my bed again i'm
wrong about the biting thing but you've
done the ship thing you've done the ship
thing okay my point is is for a man
that's scared about germ exchange you
shouldn't offer people sips then you're
not saying it made me write about the
sneeze i'm saying i panicked and i'm
apologizing incessantly about the sneeze
i made a mistake i hate when people
cough and don't cover their mouths i
think it's disgusting i don't like if
somebody sneezes and doesn't whatever i
agree but i panicked in a moment where i
was sitting a foot away from a man that
just had a nervous breakdown about a
spider plant or a snake plant and i just
i panicked and i just did the wrong
these are at the top of my list of
things that i it feels like it's it's an
assault it feels like it's it's it's
weaponizing it's a person weaponizing
their own germs
not maybe not by any fault of their own
i think the fans should weigh in
and decide
like what's worse than a seas we should
honestly argue something sneak something
by the way before the fans weigh in
before any of you weigh in i am not
saying what i did is great i'm saying i
panicked wait wait wait should we make
and i did
versus something sneezing i know what
i'm saying is
what's worse a guy sharing a drink with
you or a guy sneezing downward like that
away from you i'll take the guy sneezing
downward away from me over a guy sharing
a drink with me any day of the week
should we should we change this battle i
mean we were gonna there was there was
burping versus farting on the table but
it might be farting or versus sneezing
no no farting versus burping is that is
that okay but
but
memory card and see what really happened
about what when he
oh you're going to be going to the
slow-mo videotape on that one you're
going to see my face like
just know
again
i did not think that was the right thing
to do
i panicked and in a moment of panic i
turned and my intention was to do this
now if i didn't do exactly that i
apologize i also apologize for me not
thinking and making the right decision
in the panic but that's all it was was a
panic okay
i'll tell you another thing what i can't
believe we do
i can't believe we use microphones
now as you you notice when we go on tour
i make them give me my own mic
because i can't like and i'm
i'm trusting them that it's sanitized
but the clubs now they stopped doing the
mic switch and like that's like a week
of that doesn't that mic doesn't get
washed now it got washed between every
comic
for that whole
time period to placate everyone but now
it doesn't get washed at all
you see
so now it's you know four shows a night
eight six comics show seven shows a week
four weeks a month you know what i'm
saying yeah when you when you take a mic
when at the club you put it up to your
there's
a hundred people's
i don't worry i don't worry about this
stuff because
as a bachelor
that goes on dates and whatever it's
like
uh what am i gonna do i'm doing the
worst thing you could possibly do when
you kiss a stranger
yeah but you're committing to one person
that you have a read on i don't know
where the hell they've been you don't
know where the 100 comics have been that
would have been you know what i mean i
don't think you have
i i never really thought the the um
the the cleaning the mic thing was i
thought it had i thought it was
pointless so that was stupid
when they said you couldn't get covet
anymore from um from surfaces i just
didn't see the point of it well i have a
bad habit when i'm on stage i rest the
mic right here
so so when i'm talking i'm resting the
mic on my chin a little bit like this
yeah i mean maybe it's i don't know
yeah i guess so because it's like the
glass thing i guess right where you get
you could i don't i don't know i don't
know
i can't do you know i don't
i don't if i'm being frank i don't know
all i can think about right now is is
there an express oh here we go
yeah
oh you got it you you're going to the
videotape right now oh my god there it
is
let's see it oh
slow-mo there's all sorts of microscopic
[ __ ] coming out
here he goes here he goes
it looks like you spit a lookie
oh my god oh
it's gross it's crazy
he's afraid he got some on his hands
look what he does with his hand right
after watch this watch here look his
hand is right there his hand is right
there to cover his mouth it's right
there
he puts he jumps there and then he takes
his hand and he wipes
and then
oh my god it's disgusting
everyone here is gonna get sick nobody's
i'm not sick to his credit he didn't
even it didn't he didn't even turn his
head at you
but but but he sneezed he sneezed and
then he then he wiped his hand then he
touched here he touched here that is
you should
go wash my hands anti-back you got to do
it you got i'm afraid about the leather
and everything else oh sal you can't get
diseases from a surface
stop it
remember they said that about kovic
remember when they say you can't get it
from surfaces yet everybody still thinks
that you should it's still got your
sneeze on my uh i still don't want you
sneeze on it
should we watch it again let's watch it
let's let's let the fans that's what the
listeners and the viewers
oh
i don't understand
why oh
why were you able to put your hand up to
your face after the seas to wipe it all
around but not to cover it to begin you
your reasoning for dropping your hand
was you didn't want to get anything on
your hand you shot it into the room and
then wiped your mouth and nose with your
hand three different times
thereby putting it on your hands
it doesn't track what he's saying
doesn't track
it's funny it's funny with no um with no
audio to then see him talking about it
and he reenacted it he did his own
reenactments
and by the way is does the reenactment
with how accurate was the reenactment by
the way
oh
though he does nail it
make the reenactment black and white you
know and just put on the
modern dramatization
[Laughter]
okay now put your hand into the box of
cookies that are there
[Laughter]
got to thank age foley and kevin ryan
for bringing uh those cookies over
do you have one
i didn't have that one yet but i was
lying was that the only one
all right classy move
what what's the matter so good
[Laughter]
you went somewhere else
i'm so hungry
oh [ __ ]
all right okay
all right
now a word from our sponsor better help
[Music]
guys look we talk about it every week
we're all caught up in life right now
we're working to the bone everyone's got
their own issues everyone's got their
own thing i'm spread too thin i'm
freaking out about it all the time it's
important to stop down and take a moment
for your own mental health insanity
uh look we take care of stuff like our
car take care of stuff like you know
our memorabilia collection for some of
you sports fanatics out there
of that nature we got to take care of
our brain okay there are plenty of ways
to support a healthy brain like learning
a language or taking power naps but
there's also better help online therapy
uh we have been with betterhelp for a
long time now we've turned a lot of
people on to it we get a lot of good
feedback about it um you might have been
hesitant to do actual in-person therapy
this is online it can be completely
anonymous it's cheaper than regular
therapy you can start within 48 hours
it offers video phone and even live chat
therapy sessions you don't have to turn
the camera on if you don't want to uh so
yeah so this is what we're working with
here if you've ever thought about doing
it contemplate it there's no harm no
value you might as well give it a shot
our listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com taste buds
that's better
h-e-l-p-com taste buds look i don't
grill a lot i grill in the summer that's
when i grill i got the old barbecue out
back we do some strip steaks we do some
burgers i like the classics the dogs
that's why butcher box comes in huge for
me in the summer it's a subscription
service uh that delivers high quality
meat and seafood right to your doorstep
uh choose from carefully curated
selections or make your own they got 100
grass-fed beef free-range organic
chicken wild caught seafood and more you
get the idea this is quality stuff
without having to go to the store to
pick it out
the convenience every month they ship it
right to your home it's free shipping in
the united states
there are no antibiotics no hormones in
the stuff they ship they're always
packed fresh and shipped frozen for
convenience i get the box i walk it
right over i unpack it right into my my
uh my my freezer and then that's it i
don't think about oh do i have this do i
have that i kind of just go through it
and then if i if i finish some stuff
that i like and i have more of one thing
i can go in and i can customize the box
i want you can hit pause anytime if you
want to wait that month it's really
really cool um customize your own box
you go one of theirs uh delicious like
we said 100 pork raised crate free all
that kind of stuff less than six bucks a
meal on average get summer sizzling
started with this special butcher box
deal for our listeners free bacon for
the life of your membership plus ten
dollars off sign up today at
butcherbox.com
taste buds and use the code taste buds
to get one pack of free bacon in every
single box for the life of your
membership plus ten dollars off your
first order that's butcherbox.com
slash taste buds and then use the code
taste buds to claim this deal
let's talk about it raisins versus
watermelon okay
you brought up the fact today because we
we had some watermelon over there you
brought the fact today that you detest
the spies and recoil
against watermelon i said that's insane
and right there we the battle was born
we decided what is
the fruit to put with it and we ran the
gamut of fruits and the way we arrive
with raisins which people are going to
say watermelon versus raisins this
doesn't make any sense you got to
understand you got to come out of the
box do me a favor
go eat that cookie right now really i
need to see your reaction to dude it's
so good i need you to
oh my god dude it's that good
so that is
i didn't finish my rap but all right
yeah shout out to uh rispoli pastry shop
and cafe
uh on bay street in hyatt street staten
island
the guys rolled up with oh tall class by
the way the are you garbage guys are all
class there it is down there they rolled
up with a
i mean a box full of delicious delicious
cookies and pastries
go for the one with the chocolate tips
okay
wow that that s with the powdered sugar
looks dynamite
how about this one look at that that's
that's i had that jelly one oh my god
right it's no joke
there's somehow i need an app can after
this though this might somehow be better
oh my god
it's that fragile
[Laughter]
i wasn't stuffing that
thank you
how good is this
i was not expecting that
i wouldn't change him i have a
eat more over the box as god knows what
falls out of your [ __ ] mouth back in
over everybody else's cookies you
[ __ ] animal
how dare you call me now let's go to
inside edition see if they have a slow
motion of a guy eating cookies over a
box
let me do something right now
that is
is that white a lights out it's like a
cookie pastry combination that's a
life-changing cookie in my opinion is
that in there
yeah
an amaretto
when it's a little both
is it
amaretto yeah i did this it was just a
cough but i was coughing on my on the
cookie
i still did it i naturally did it
amaretto panic
in panic i sneezed i didn't cross i'm
about to cough i'm going to do what i'm
doing how dare you compare a cough to a
sneeze a sneeze is terrifying as it
approaches a cough is easy peasy yeah
beautiful covergirl
amaretto is interesting because
yes she should should i think amaretto
is interesting because out of
amaretto is an almond liqueur
but out of contest context it has like a
raspberry flavor almost or something
don't you agree that amaretto has like a
fruit flavor to it
yeah it's got like a like a cherry
cherry cherry well that's why it goes
great with cherries that's so good you
ever have a peanut butter and jelly shot
yeah we make them all the time at joey
roses
so that's it without the chocolate dip
still probably great
you know what's nice it's so chewy but
the shaved almond
the shave what is that like a marcona
almond or whatever it gives that snap in
there
i mean people you asked for us to eat
every on on the show and i said i said
it's stupid we're not going to eat on
the show you don't want to sit there and
listen to us and watch us eat
well you get what you asked for hip you
want one of these
all right fair enough you know what i'm
gonna have a beer instead
i didn't eat today all right it was
these cookies you [ __ ] up i got you a
salad
i know
i gave it i gave it away
we have two options
i'll do watermelon versus raisins oh we
could just finish this box
you can't stop
have you guys ever been to a bad bakery
does that exist
what's a bad bakery about
rye
faceless here talking to mike
i'll tell you
for now
i'll tell you what's a bad bakery
shout out shout out raspoli's yeah great
when they when they're shipping the
stuff in you can tell
when they're not baking on-prem yeah
there's plenty of bakeries
it's not even about baking on premises
it's fine if you've got to bake off site
and then bring it over
it's another thing if you're ordering
from like a mass produced
oh like a whole
company
and then like getting it in and whatever
i find now this is not always the case
some places just do this
for for convenience
but i find if you see a place and and
and they they have like whole cakes for
instance and the slices are separated
by like paper
that that often can be a red flag that
they're not baking the stuff themselves
but
there's an amazing bakery in in in
williamsburg that i'm blanking on the
name of that does bake stuff themselves
and they actually do that is it the huge
one on the corner the huge one yeah with
tables it sells coffee it's really big
it's huge it has the light lit up
outside and they're legit but they put
the paper in so they can quickly yeah
i've i've ordered from there i i
i mean it catches your eye and you walk
in you're like oh this is going to be
amazing i got a couple things they were
good i i didn't sample enough of it it
was good it wasn't the i was like i'm
roast prepared by the way they're known
for their cheesecake and their
cheesecake is is no joke
turned around and walked out yeah 100
for that reason
if i see the strawberry like if i have a
strawberry cheesecake and i look at it
and then you're going to another bakery
you're like i'm going to find another
bakery yeah
usually bakeries are like florists like
you have yours
you know you have your go-to
or on a whim you're just like oh look a
bakery let's go in and get something and
you go on your ah it's not worth the
squeeze on this one i understand that
you know yeah but like
if the other red flag to me is if like
they have like a
strawberry
cheesecake and you and it's got that
like
do you know what i'm talking about
you're like that's generic oh yeah like
the compote on top yeah it's like that
gel yeah you're like that's yeah that's
the mass produced yeah this isn't the
real deal uh i tell you about bakery
cookies for me
probably better than any cookie that you
could possibly purchase in a store like
i'll put it up i know i'm an oreo guy
and oreo demolish ships ahoy in episode
one
i don't know if it was a demolishment
but they won i would put bakery cookies
up against anything
i'm a cookie guy man you you're not i am
right well i mean look you know we bring
something like that home
i like cookies quite a bit i'm just
saying next to cake i like cake better
but you hand me a cookie like that a
fresh bacon
that's a cookie multiple different
things we just ate was a cake cookie
that was best of both worlds yeah that
was delicious
i mean i'll do that all day long i'm sad
i didn't dunk it
you know what i mean like now the harder
cookies in there are still good but
they're nowhere near as intriguing to me
as those like chewy cakey cookies you
know what's crazy as a kid i didn't like
like
i would like the bakery cookies that
were dipped in chocolate or
with the gel jelly in the middle or you
know chocolate chips or or this rainbow
cookies right and i didn't like what i
thought would like the coffee treats
essentially the yes cookies you know the
i'm going to blanket all the names but
those are still not that good the ones
with the sesame seeds on them and stuff
the uh
the name is that's like old-school
italian right yeah and i was always like
the panoli's and all that stuff and i
was always like nah as a kid i pass on
it now i'm like yo that's where it's at
that's that's amazing
i'm still not huge on those except for
patel's patel's are the big one i came
around on when i was a kid
i wouldn't across the street for patel
now i'm like oh man
that's like having like a little pancake
or something i mean it's so good yeah oh
they are good oh is that the chocolate
ones too
my mom makes someone with the skin wafer
with the chocolate
it's like it's like those are the ones
you're making like the waffle iron that
are like this thin but they got the
design in them
you know what i'm talking about
pimp google pixels it's p-i-t i think
it's p-i-t-z-e-l-l-e-s
yeah there it is
oh dude those are so good man
with black coffee after dinner forget it
did you were you the person who told me
that lindsay tartt could go take a walk
forget what a lin
a linda tart is two butter cookies
uh with a hole in the middle sandwiched
into a raspberry filling with dusted
powdered sugar on top that's a wonderful
cookie i probably did say that in a fit
of uh uh
ego
you get one of those
fresh baked
clear your evening
today
no i think it's a
what do you i don't know
yeah we should go to battle i felt
sodium up top
a little bit all right then let's but we
don't know i i don't want to i i think
we're already hovering
over it's lovely i love you i know ready
yeah
we're right i just got my i just got my
heather gray
really soft awesome no matter what
happens i love you hoodie in the mail
and i love it and i also got the brand
new graffiti old school taste buds uh
logo with the crown on it in the in the
mail as well where's mine i don't know
why don't you tell me one what is that i
don't know why they didn't send it to
you i should show i should show you what
is this i don't get one
i should show you if you wanted to do
that i could show you yeah yeah i wore
it on camera already on the show the
what the taste buds it's like this it
actually has it's a tribe called quest
but it's like you know what it looks
like wait a minute where did you
you were the taste buds one on joker's
you mean correct
hey guys maybe send me one too
do you think they sit here and watch
unreal yeah well
all right ready
yes
sneeze my [ __ ] face no matter what
happens i love you the better whatever i
love you no matter what happens i love
you all right all right time to
b-a-t-t-l-e but here we go
you know what bothers me about that they
sent me the blue god bless shirt your
merch before they're sending me my own
merch oh that's hysterical maybe they
mixed it up
i didn't i didn't ask them to send you a
blue god bless
the studio in the font yep no i asked
for a blue god bless i wanted one oh
awesome but i'm saying
why am i getting that before getting my
own merch well i didn't ask for those
but i think they came in late when we
got our first shipment they weren't in
it i already had oh see i already had
the no matter what happens hoodie
did you just oh no no i'm wrong i got
the taste but the new taste buds
graffiti and i got the new hey babe
hoodie
that's what i got they weren't in stock
at first
i'm really irritated that i did not want
to show you it too it's really nice i'll
look at it later
it's it's it's it's actually awesome
because i'm
[Music]
all right we're back check out these
buttes
this they had
this is awesome yes
it's the
the hoodie
and then we have it in the t-shirt but
this is the you have this right oh yeah
no matter what happens i love you hoodie
that i have you wear that out you wear
that dress set up you dress that down
it's you know you have a little chill
you put throw it on you know what i'm
saying it's nice maybe you're on the
beach there's a breeze going you having
a bonfire great hoodie for that i agree
and this is the new shirt now we're
gonna see
this is the new shirt you baste it off
of
this like this kind of this kind of job
this
old school hip-hop vibe
the colors are awesome actually oh that
looks good
doesn't that look good dude it does
and these are my favorite t-shirt this
is one of those
classic comfort colors yeah these
comfort colors are just great
look at that isn't that dope
the color palette remember they did like
we went through a few different
variations of this to really get the
colors to like pop yeah that really
looks nice with the crown and everything
i mean it's dope that's great yeah
that's great
good they did a really good job on that
oh i'll have to buy one for myself
all right
always the bridesmaid anyway the reason
the reason let me just adjust myself
[Laughter]
um
he got the first sleepy joe merch out
there now this this there's dozens of
incidences
now i'm having joe's friend send me
photos of him sleeping at parties
[Laughter]
so who sent you that one uh
somebody okay a sleepy josie
oh that's so funny oh dude my boy vince
averill from we watch wrestling podcast
great podcast check it out it's very
very fun and especially if you like
wrestling but he's got
dude he's got the gamut
he's got pictures of me from every party
in los angeles sleeping
it's almost like it should be like a
website
like when i lived out there he's got
pictures tumblr or something yeah dude
i'll actually hit him up i'd love to
make a coffee table book it's just him
sleeping on every page yeah all right
there's more to come i have a i have a
bunch
there's more to come yeah i probably
have one
we had a party here one time he went
into the bedroom and went in bed and
slept
like not he didn't doze off he he sought
bed snap
add it to the collection
you sought bed bro he sought bed all
right
i hate watermelon yeah so he hated
watermelon i was like what i said what
could i go against we went through a lot
of fruits okay because i don't i already
did a grapefruit i didn't like
grapefruit we did that in an old battle
strawberries were a few weeks back and
they're
we we landed on raisins and the reason
is
twofold one was
arguably i think watermelon seems to be
like the largest of the fruits
as a whole and then you know
raisins
yeah conversely raisins are the smallest
of the fruits so it's almost like the
biggest fruit versus pretty much the
smallest fruit second was that we found
both of them to be polarizing i didn't
know this until he told me but
apparently people despise watermelon
it's a lovely relationship with the
watermelon and i i would venture to say
it's a love-hate relationship with the
very raisins some people hate the
watermelon i can't stand it when
somebody i have argued about watermelon
outside of this podcast more times than
i can remember probably more than i've
ever argued about a food in my life i
get annoyed when i ge i don't how has
this not come up until now then i don't
know i get annoyed when somebody tells
me they love it i get annoyed when
somebody tells me that they think it's
sweet why do you get annoyed with the
person who because i think it is a
tasteless fruit i don't understand why
people go it's so sweet it has almost no
flavor to me watermelon flavored things
are you not eating right watermelon is
that what's happening
i've had it
i've had a dog many many times in my
life
uh
sweet i guess maybe it's just maybe it's
because there's no tartness to it that
it just tastes just sugar sweet to me
and i'm getting nothing out even though
even the sweetest watermelon
is is still
not that sweet which was is amazing even
the most fruitful watermelon that's what
i don't like i like it it's it's it's
not like over like i can't take like a
kiwi
or a strawberry those things just it's
too much the watermelon is cool and
refreshing i love that you could the
let's get into it if you want okay i
think it is a bland fruit i love i think
it's meal i love i love watermelon
chunks i love watermelon
the best is like a pizza slice when you
cut into a slice and you have the whole
rind that you're able to hold and you
can eat it and there's a snap to it and
you eat it right down to the rind nice
and clean it
can tell you how many times
it's it's
it's it's very very hydrating how many
times well well yeah water melon right
but i can't tell you how many times it's
fun i was handed a slice of watermelon
and i saw that beautiful pink
and the beautiful green
and the even like a bit of a yellowish a
yellowish white in there and all i would
think about is the flavors i usually
associate with those colors
cherry strawberry lime
the the ca the texture of it water icy
and i'd expect to bite into it and get
this like rocket pop flavor and you bite
into it and it's just this mealy watery
flavorless
you should you also then have to spit
the seeds out of your mouth with the
nature
of the watermelon is not mealy you keep
talking about a mealy watermelon it is
it's not the nature of it is the texture
of the watermelon mealy one it's mealy i
don't know the texture of the watermelon
flesh
is it's it's got a it's got a it's got a
texture to it that i don't care for you
you ever florist when they have that
weird like green
spongy thing yeah that they put like
yeah the watermelon texture almost
reminds me of that yeah that to me is
mealy man have you ever had a rotten
watermelon that's disgusting no i don't
think i have i used to work
and i had to deal with rotten
watermelons your whole i would be
covered in my shoulders in watermelon
and it's so
smells like a corpse
yeah that's gross yeah fruit when it
goes bad is rough stuff you have to go
to a
guys magic spoon is back with the taste
buds podcast right now in my cabinet i
have frosted i have fruit i have peanut
butter i have chocolate um i love cereal
i stopped with the cereal because it's
loaded with sugar and i was like i had
to be responsible this is
guilt-free cereal that is packed with
protein it's 140 calories 13 to 14 grams
of protein four or five net carbs in
each serving it's low carb it's keto
friendly it's gluten free it's grain
free it's soy free come on it's almost
free and it's only 140 calories and the
thing is like a lot of these cereals you
taste them we just recently did
something on this on the worst cereal we
did an episode of worst cereals and this
cereal actually finally tastes like the
cereal you like to to eat when you're a
kid you know the ones you love they pack
with protein there's a flavor for
everyone um build your own box uh and or
go with their classics uh you can mix
them up like mixing up cocoa and peanut
butter and all that good jazz uh
blueberry muffin maple waffle and honey
nut are some of their newest flavors i
haven't tried those looking forward to
it go to magicspoon.com taste buds to
grab a custom bundle of cereal and try
the magic for yourself and be sure to
use our promo code
taste buds on top of that at checkout to
save five dollars off the order and
magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's back with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any single reason they'll fund
your money zero questions asked if
everything was like that it'd be a
different world remember get your next
delicious bowl of guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com
taste buds and use that code taste buzz
to save five dollars off thank you magic
spoon for sponsoring this episode guys i
wish we had things like upstart about 20
years ago when i was a college student
working through my
my my college debt my credit card debt
um
man it sucked but now we have things
like this it can be hard like it could
be hard we're all in this we've all been
in this situation some of you listening
right now are it's hard to see the light
at the end of the tunnel when you have
high interest debt high interest credit
card debt uh and sometimes it's even
hard to ask for help you know so this is
what uh upstart does okay take one of
your first steps toward financial
independence um
we've all been there upstart is powered
by personal law it's powered
sorry let me take that over pimp okay
okay
upstart powered personal loans can help
you pay down those high interest debts
all online with simple and easy to
understand payments uh upstart has
helped over one point million custom 1.8
million customers on their path to
financial freedom whether it's paying
off the credit cards consolidating the
high interest debt or maybe even funding
a personal expense um
upstart can help you get it done with
fixed monthly payments with a clear
payoff date they know you're more than
just your credit store so
rather than looking at just your credit
score their model considers other
factors like your income your employment
and other information provided in your
loan application so they can give you a
smarter rate for your loan uh check your
rate within minutes for loans between
1000 to fifty thousand dollars without
even impacting credit score uh you can
receive funds as fast as a business day
after accepting your loan so don't wait
check out your rate today why not at
upstart.com taste buds that's
upstart.com
buds to check your rate today don't
forget to use our url and let them know
we sent you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit score
your income and certain other
information providing your loan
application go to upstart.com tastebuds
i love when they make they make the
watermelon the centerpiece of the of the
fruit they make it into a they carve it
out into a fruit pan
the other fruit is sitting in the
watermelon with its own handle i love
when you could slice watermelons in half
you ever have a spiked watermelon and
you ever go to a party and people soak
the watermelon in vodka overnight
and you get a kick in the nuts with that
i've heard of it they have seedless
watermelon although i don't mind the
seeds i love picking out a watermelon
it's fun it's it's actually when i leave
the supermarket with a watermelon i also
feel like no matter what i'm getting a
great deal because the watermelon is so
huge and heavy but then it's only a few
bucks and i just feel like what a what a
fantastic deal i can cut it up it's
gonna feed so many different people and
i just like it it's a nice palette
cleanser okay bargain box light and
refreshing it's a bargain buy which is
not always the best thing in the world
scoop it out into little balls you ever
see them do that yeah i love that too no
care whatever form you put [ __ ] into it
watermelon juice a watermelon juice
watermelon
yeah it's good for you i guess it's it's
so again i see a big thing of pink juice
and i get so excited at how flavorful
it's going to be i mean you drink it and
it has no it tastes like somebody put
sugar into watered-down kool-aid or
something it's just great it's just a
subtle hint like it it's enough however
it is something i think that you're so
bogged down with sugary drinks
waterproof no no it's not peeled it's
not true watermelon flavored things like
watermelon flavored gum tastes the way i
want watermelon to taste that tastes too
sweet they inject it with too much sugar
it's got tartness talk about the raisin
fruit
i'm not interested the reason
i need tartness in the fruit there's got
to be a tartness with this i love a
tartness and actually raisins don't have
a tartness so i guess i'm a little bit
wrong no yes they do yes they do the
raisins raisins first of all bursting
with flavor first of all the raisin
bursting
the raisin is a shriveled lump of
doesn't matter
[Music]
and the fact that it's still doing as
well as it is
speaks to it speaks to to just the the
how great of a product i disagree
wholeheartedly
the reason is it first of all it looks
like a little cockroach no it does yes
it does no it does when i was little it
took me a while to get used to eating
uh raisin bran because it looked like i
just had a bowl of cereal with a bunch
of you can't sit next to a plant with
the wrong kind of leaves on it i mean
what are we talking about you're saying
that if i threw a bunch of raisins on
the floor and you walked into a room and
your eye went down real quick you
wouldn't think they were a little bit if
you threw a bunch of more watermelon on
the floor i think somebody's brains got
blown all over the place what are we
talking about here we're talking about
flavor about you talking about
consistency and mealiness the reason is
you take raisins the raisin is sticky
it's chewy it gets stuck in your teeth
no not if you buy bad raisins if you buy
a good oh when a raisin hardens that's
another thing but yeah but that's a bad
reason that's like thinking about mealy
all right but i'm talking about you get
a good raisin you get a good quality
raisin no sugar added just a straight up
and down plump raisin you throw a
handful of those into your mouth it is a
flavor escapade it's wonderful
and then talk about a mixer you can yeah
well have a good time chocolate covered
raisins choc raisins mixed with salted
mixed with salted nuts raisin bread
raisin bran raisin toast raisins
oh my god the golden raisin versus the
uh
versus the standard raisin uh the the
the like the raising by the way
the raisin the raisin is worse off than
where it came from the grape is one in
my top five fruits
okay
the raisin comes from a grape
grape is in my top five you don't [ __ ]
with a grape but grape don't need to be
[ __ ] with a grape is amazing a grape
becomes a raisin it's not as good as it
once was it's like it's different it's
like it's like an aging grape it's like
a grape that's shriveled
that's
it's two different it's two different
experiences it's two different flavors
and the fact that the grape can evolve
raisins better than a grape i didn't say
that i said it's two different foods
i'm saying we could have done grapes
versus raisins it's too yeah we could
have but it's two different experiences
it's two different experiences i love
the compactness and convenience of a
raisin i love that you get raisins on
the go i love that raisins are the or
that are the cornerstone of any good
trail
raisin raisin is is is is
is fake fruit
it's you buy it in a box off a shelf
it's pumped with i don't buy my raisins
it's a box i buy memories loose no i buy
them in a bag because i buy a quality
brand of raisin where you're getting
like a natural no [ __ ] added raisins
you don't go to the to the produce
section the way you pick out a
watermelon the cantaloupe oh good razors
you usually stash where like the nuts
are and stuff like that
and i usually buy him in a bag you know
he's got a great uh raisin selection uh
and a decent quality in store raisin uh
trader joe's trader joe's has a decent
shout out trader joe's if you're
watching and we know that you are
i i gotta tell you uh when do you get
raisins how often do would you say you
get raisins every week part of my show
they are part of my weekly diet
you have seen me come in here and this
is true you buy raisins weekly you have
seen me come in here i've got raisins in
my cabinet right now but do you buy them
weekly i buy them when i run out of them
i eat them weeks no but this is my point
i'm trying to make i get raisins in the
house sometimes they exist
but my raisins are in the house for two
three years no you have a handful at
first then they get dry and then you
just keep that guy you lift up and you
go 2014
the bag i buy usually lasts me about two
weeks
and then i get a new bag so how often
are you eating raisins what'd you say
several days a week are you serious
several days a week you eat raisins
several days a week you keep on a
straight face you eat raisins several
days a week you have seen me come into
this apartment with a bag
or a cup that i have filled pimp you've
seen me do it with nuts with cashew
pieces and raisins yeah we ain't talking
about a trail next buddy
if you need if you need the cashew and
the pecan and all that stuff i don't
need a raisin i don't know
hold on a second i don't need anything
are you talking trail mix that you eat
several days a week or raisins
sal i buy raisins and nuts every week
and i eat them throughout the week
sometimes i eat them together if i'm on
the go and i didn't have time to have a
meal yes i mixed them because it's a
harder snack to eat if i if i know i'm
gonna
record for instance without having lunch
or something like that i didn't do it
today foolishly and now i'm four [ __ ]
cake cookies in but the point is
yeah is did get me a salad but it was
too involved then i never ate god i made
your own [ __ ] he got nervous
but i bring it for that reason
convenience that's one of the things i
hate about the watermelon it is the
elite fruit should be a travel
travelable
meal
fruit juice why
fruit should be able to be eaten on the
go why fruit because i s because i said
so how about that that's what you're
gonna you're gonna give that edict to
all fruits yeah because fruit is a water
should every vegetable be on the balcony
yeah and there's plenty of walking eats
but all fruit to say all fruits should
be walking the fact that watermelon has
it's not impossible i said it's purpose
cut out your melons which they're all
useless cantaloupe natural honey i hate
the anti-melon movement i love melon
it's mango a melon if it is it's the
only one worth eating mangoes amazing
mango's incredible mango might be a
melon is mango a melon
i think so how about his mango a melon
it's a drew no it's a drooper what's it
just it is first time i've ever heard
that stone fruit d-r-u-p-e stone fruit
stone fruit is a dream of the list of
melons
flashy a fleshy fruit with thin skin and
a central stone contain it's a stone
fruit okay
give me a list of melons
i never said i'm gonna eat this droop
real quick
cantaloupe terrible watermelon terrible
pumpkin terrible
really crook neck
oh it's another pumpkin terrible
honeydew terrible
zucchini is a melon vita wrote to me
about a honeydew honey duty
melon i mean even zucchini is like a
peanut
zucchini it's wonderful it's okay it's a
squash it's okay it's terrific squash
can go go scratch
[Music]
come come come around fall and say that
about the zucchini you'll be out you're
on the streets
listen you get a piece of you get you
get i'm not saying it's impossible to to
enjoy a zucchini but i'm just saying
even those aren't bringing much it's
like it's like people tell me they don't
like billy joel
i get it i'm sick and tired of them too
sometimes somebody will deny it you
can't deny maddie wrote
hi maddie she wrote i know deroza chose
raising so that's getting really hard to
defend him there you go now can i tell
you something else i don't like about
raisins
yeah okay i don't like how my hands feel
when i'm eating them and that's right
wait i never finished my point
of all the fruits
that are convenient watermelon is the
most inconvenient it's a giant thing
needs to be sliced needs to be eaten
over a plate it's a it's messy it's it's
just it's a convenience so you cut it up
i mean then i put it in tupperware and
cubes and i have that [ __ ] all week but
everybody goes oh you walk with a slice
of watermelon it's like it's dripping
all over your chin down your shirt it's
terrible
you when i stick my hand into raisins
and pull them out then my hands get this
raisin glaze buying bad raisins dude i'm
telling you my hands it's a raisin glaze
just sticky by nature
you're raising hydrated
a bad raisin no i'm not as a matter of
fact the only time a reason is not
sticky it's when it when it's old and
it's getting hardened he's not paying
attention anything i'm saying
i'm not i just uh
we're we're we're at the phones no we're
not at the phones what time is it yes we
are what no we're at the phone what not
yes i got to tell you sitting in a chair
i don't know
in a more airy environment but it goes
faster read away because i think
um
you have you have something that weighs
10 pounds that is fun to buy that you
can cut in half and spike with vodka you
can cut out and make it to a basket to
house all the fruit it's it's
you can
let me finish
watermelon flavor also permeates every
single thing you can think of
shut up yes it does idiot did you ever
get a raisin flavored lollipop a raisin
in flavor no but no no no
but i'm not making the claim that
watermelon doesn't permeate everything
you can ever one of them is all over
babe it's all over okay can you drink
raisin juice
no
where is where is the raisin besides a
cinnamon raisin pizza raisin is all
raisin bread only the cornerstone trail
mix
first fruit to permeate the breakfast
cereal the cornerstone of trail mix the
first fruit to enter into the candy
department don't you talk to me about
this go to the phones
go to the phones you got four four four
uses for raisins go ahead trail mix
raisinets
cereal great and and you can make a
basket out of a watermelon that's a
great argument
come on dude watermelon's a party
watermelon is the party
you show up let me show you a question
you show up to a party with a watermelon
acceptable or not hell yeah or no you
show up to the same party with a big
races like their [ __ ] magic beans you
will get kicked out of that party you
don't show to a party with raisins
raisins are for old people that that
that that need digestive help uh listen
i have no doubt that i'm gonna get
clobbered in this thing
but i mean it's just
i'm gonna get clobbered go to the phones
go to the phones okay raisins can be
okay but only if you add them to things
on their own they can [ __ ] right off i
agree dan
continue
i'm not ever really a watermelon person
but i eat a whole bowl of it before i
pick raisins
it's not really up for debate
disrespectful putting raisins up against
watermelon it's like asking would you
like a refreshing sweet treat or would
you rather eat a box of dried rabbit
turds thank you
if it weren't for babies and old people
with no teeth raisins would have no
purpose on this planet and don't even
think of bringing up oatmeal raisin
cookies because they suck
i don't agree that i'll give that to you
on that last one i'm not understanding
the match-up well you guys think outside
the box watermelon of course unless it's
golden raisins
see here's what i don't like raisin fans
be like here's what i do why eat a juicy
tasty fruit like watermelon when you can
eat wrinkly rat [ __ ] here's here's what
i don't like about what the responses
are and i don't like when people do this
and somebody's going to go oh here goes
darosa again saying i'm not saying
anybody's working again that's not what
i'm going to say
what i don't like is
people are going but but the refreshing
one
it's like it is refreshing i understand
it's delightful it's refreshing it's
hydrated let me finish you know what's
funny no stop the watermelon is hydrated
the raisin is dehydrated let me finish
let me finish my point is this
i'm very aware that one is refreshing
and one isn't they're two different
types of foods we're not talking about
which food is more refreshing sure we
are
no no no but we're talking about the the
benefits and the pros of each food i
just think it's it's a watermelon's
refreshing or raisin is not that's easy
it isn't
i never said i i want to have a
refreshing raisin but but but i'm not
arguing that a raisin is refreshing do
you understand what it means to bring
people hydration and refreshment what
does a raisin bring you what does it
bring you
what does it give you what does it offer
what do you think about when you think
of a raisin what do you think about what
are some words that come to mind when
you think of a raisin please indulge
sticky shriveled
sweet literally like chewy we argued
it's literally like and shut the [ __ ] up
until i finish
it's literally like if we are a sore
throat it's literally like if we argued
uh um
uh you know um
coca-cola versus milkshake and the
argument kept being
i don't drink a milkshake when i'm
thirsty and it's like no [ __ ] you don't
but that's not what the argument is the
argument is the qualities of one versus
the qualities of the other right and
what you can't do is just focus on the
fact that one is a refreshing food and
the other isn't why the other isn't
supposed to be a refreshing food so what
is it supposed to be it's supposed to be
a [ __ ] great snack that's delicious
okay so you say that as as a benefit of
the raisin and i'll say that the
watermelon is refreshing you're telling
me i can't make the argument it's the
system of the podcast my point is is
that every single comment here is about
how the watermelon is refreshing how
about the fact that raisins are the
cornerstone stone of oatmeal any [ __ ]
oatmeal you get raisins most breakfast
cereals raisins
chocolate chocolate bars raisins
chocolate covered candy raisins uh
cookies raisins raisins are [ __ ]
awesome you know one thing that you
didn't say raisins raisins because you
need to put a raisin into something else
to make it palatable my point is just
[ __ ]
you have a watermelon salad with a
little uh feta cheese mint and some
a little bit of pistachio
are you kidding me
you talk about a salad man you talk
about watermelon
sucks and you're stupid if you like it
all right it's a [ __ ] reasons for sure
if you're 90 years old that was a fun
rug pull yeah no that's fun to see in
that joke for the 78th time in the
threat
uh
raisins are only good when covered in
chocolate or yogurt
i need to know who
picked who the [ __ ] picked raisins
watermelon who the hell likes raisins
uh tons of people watermelon is a sweet
refreshing treat you eat after a day in
the pool raisins are what you
raisins are what you begrudgingly call
your fingers while you're eating that
watermelon oh that's funny nook is in
the pool your fingers turn into raisins
shriveled disgusting
i mean is this a question watermelon is
delicious raisins are to be
put in a child's lunchbox
thrown away when they inevitably get
brought back home there is no way in
hell there is no way in hell
every single person in this thread
finds raisins repulsive and disgusting
spitting everywhere now it's impossible
it is statistically impossible you're
seeing it you see it no it's a bunch of
people trying to be funny
stop
i picked raisins as a pity vote for joe
there you go oh yeah this this couldn't
in any way be the face
i think it's racist for me to pick
watermelon a black gentleman so i have
to go with raisins in potato salad or
whatever the white joke is
i
either if either of you bring up getting
raisins while trick-or-treating as a
positive argument i'm unsubscribing
you were a minute away from that uh who
would ever pick a shriveled dried grape
over this beautiful lump that looks like
tuna that looks like raw tuna it's
disgusting
not just because they
they'd clog up my
ostomy just keep going it's stupid it's
a dumbbell okay if you chose raisins i
feel sorry for you truly
is this really a battle i mean who would
pick raises
wait wait wait seven
[Music]
wait wait i i think we end this when we
get a positive for raisins i i we
haven't found one hold on you know joe
took i refused to vote that's the 70
[ __ ]
six times somebody said that
this is so obvious
dude uh if there was dear lord the only
person on this planet
that thinks raisins is better than
watermelon has got to be joe de rosa
this is proof positive of what i said
people pick the thing that they think
sal picked and they're being overly
[ __ ] obnoxious about the other
choices that's two people out of a
hundred joe not one but
you can't find a positive version so we
have skipped so many that have said it
was
go right raisins are the old school
version of the great
version the raisins are the old scrotum
version of the grape like we all know
it's seen better years and i still
still can't probably get the job done i
agree this isn't
fair
raisins don't stand a chance i
don't like either
but year-round even the shell of a melon
is reusable
but for craft food you can infuse the
melon with assorted liquids
possibilities are endless something is
wrong with you whoever picked raisins
they sit on the shelves indefinitely
nothing fresh or refreshing about them
this might this may be
the biggest margin of win ever what was
that oh joe oh [ __ ] oh
go okay go get go
go get a towel towel
uh hurry up
uh and let's just go into the
the bathroom there's a hand towel
hanging there
[ __ ]
oh lord
this [ __ ] guy
joe god joe he smells the rest of it
what the [ __ ]
there's paper towels under the sink i
want to go on record
hey i want to go on hold on i want to go
on record as saying
that before this battle started
i wanted to battle
watermelon versus popsicles why because
both are a refreshing summer treat and
sal insisted it was too similar and we
had to go crazy
i didn't say it was too similar i just
said i don't get that match up how do
you not get it nobody gets this match
because one is ice versus a fruit i just
didn't get it nobody gets dispatched we
have to we explain it to them at the top
they don't understand it's the biggest
fruit versus the smallest fruit we're
gonna get it and it's i'm gonna get the
loss of a lifetime because we just
joe do me a favor don't start
doing a different yarn here okay don't
start sewing a different yarn you picked
a you said what do you not like cherries
i said i love cherries you said uh
whatever else i said i love that and
then i said i don't really love raisins
you go i [ __ ] love raisins i go but
do they match up and we said well it's
the biggest fruit versus smallest fruit
and also people love and hate raisins
and people love and hate watermelon
apparently you told me you told me i
said i never heard of that you said
believe me people have a love-hate
relationship with watermelons
well that's how they feel about no no no
no no no i was not the person that said
that but you agreed to it i you heard it
i said i said i hate it how are you and
then we said oh well you know raisins
have that same trait people love
mohammed and we both said great we have
our battle don't now try to come in here
and backtrack i just want to make it
sound like i denied you i just want to
point out for every single comment on
here saying but a watermelon is
defending i wanted to argue a refreshing
thing versus a refreshing thing but then
why did you accept raisins as the best
because we were going to be there for
another 58 minutes trying to figure it
out
your horse don't complain at the finish
line okay pick your horse in the
beginning okay jesus i can't wait for
the episode whoever pick raisins is a
dope yep
i even take
i'd even take dried up watermelon over a
crusty dusty raisin
joe i i i yeah
i i don't know what's going on here man
we we haven't found a s
fi just find me one [ __ ] racism
there's no way on earth everybody
a wet fruit over a dried fruit there is
no way i am god's earth freeze mim i am
i prefer a wet fruit over dry fruit i am
speechless to whoever chooses raisins
over watermelon just know that
you're loved and cared
juicy watermelon and something that
looks like my grandfather's ball pick
yeah
let's give that the win we got to wrap
it up we're way way way behind school
this has never happened though we should
we should lean and this has never
happened in the history of our program
we we couldn't find a single comment for
reasons yep
couldn't couldn't couldn't all be people
just trying to [ __ ] with me couldn't
couldn't all be we saw so many comments
that i mean you think everything
couldn't couldn't possibly be you think
that everyone's just trying to be
[ __ ] funny right now and make their
little [ __ ] jokes instead of actually
voting you don't think you don't you
think every listener is conspiring
against you that's what you think
you think that you what do you think
everybody's going on here blind you
think they're not leading the threat
you think they're not reaching
joe every you spit all over me for the
fourth time you you god damn it you're
gonna get this whole house ill look at
me sick look at me that doesn't i still
don't want you germs look at me look at
me you know you have your fans you get
team deroses all the time you get all
that stuff i love you you see it all the
time where are they now they cannot
defend
first of all the people that are leaving
these comments they don't know who chose
what you dick they're sure as hell
guessing it pretty good some of them are
guessing it you i would say 95 percent
don't know who to take it listen
our winner is take the huge l follow
y a films
uh he's our
he's yes he's our winner uh and then all
right pimp let's can you imagine we go
and raise him
i i want a drumroll here on this humble
pie segment
why it's gonna be the worst i i i wanna
10 000 votes um
our biggest margin of victory ever was
was we didn't we never got 90 plus right
it was like 80s to high teens low high
low 80s to high teens i don't know about
this one man i don't know i think this
is going to be out of control let's
check this out
[Laughter]
before we do this
like and subscribe like and subscribe
guys go to uh follow us at no presh
on youtube just go to youtube type in no
pressure that's where the video is if
you guys are audio listeners you can
check out the video if you guys are
video listeners the audio comes out at
midnight the night before the video
doesn't come out till 11am so you could
actually hear the pod at midnight the
night before that's a bonus and you can
hear it on your commute or whatever you
want to do um and then you can buy our
merch yeah then you come back and you
can watch it at 11. anyway that's the
way you support the pod it's a free pod
click this link to buy the merch
it's in the description
all right
all right here we go babes this is going
to be something here here we go
wow
it's actually not as bad as i thought i
didn't either and pimp you voted raisins
wow you were silent this whole time a
lot of people like raisins your closet
raisin in the closet a lot of people
like race it's i think it's still our
biggest margin of victory ever
i think it is it's 85.5 watermelon 14.5
raisins but i got to tell you so that's
like uh
9 out of 10 people but we read about 100
things which means by that measure we
should have gotten 10 positive raisin
comments yeah well you know like how
people on the internet never just see
what everybody else is doing and pile on
that never happens on twitter you don't
think these people are so weird you
don't think these people are telling
their true feelings you think they just
tell you what i think pilates rub it up
your ass yeah sneeze your way back to
manhattan
i still love you babe
[Laughter]
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste but